so
uh
good afternoon dear colleagues
can i ask you kindly to sit down
the session that adjourned on the 20th
of january 2022 is reopened
the minutes and the texts adopted of the
sittings of 17th 18th 19th and 28th of
january
are available
if there are no comments i will deem
these minutes to be
approved
a few announcements from my end uh mr
jerome riviere and mr gilbert kolar are
no longer members of the id group and
now sit with the non-attached members as
from the 25th
of january
the renew europe and id groups have
notified me of decisions relating to
changes to appointments within
committees and delegations and those
decisions will be set out
in the minutes of today's sitting and
shall take effect on the date of this
announcement
and finally the draft agenda as opposed
as adopted by the conference of
presidents on the 20th of january
pursuant to rule 157 has been
distributed and is adopted
now as you know
today
we are marking the international
holocaust remembrance day with a formal
address by miss margot friedlander
miss friedlander i am honored to welcome
you to the european parliament and i
thank you for being here today as
witness of the holocaust
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the visit was really hard the site is
really something that changes the person
nothing really prepares you for the real
experience this whole
visit is part of our common history
[Music]
you heard your steps working in the snow
a lot of people walk in the same way but
they never return so it's so hard to
be part of the history in that place
with that
feelings today i
finally managed to see in first person
what happened how it happened and
the people that were
involved in what happened through
pictures names dates and personal
objects if someone asks me what videos
are here i will
just
tell them to come and see with their own
eyes
it's a must visit for everyone it's
experience you have to make once a
lifetime there are no words to describe
this place
i think the most shocking for me was
seeing personal items like shoes because
that makes you think that behind every
pair of shoes there was someone who
maybe bought them for special occasion
to go dance or for a special night out
with their family and they never got the
chance to do so again
[Music]
i never thought about their
feelings
i never thought about that and that's
what i learned here how the [ __ ] felt
[Music]
it happened that maybe it's going to
happen again
these words
went into my mind and they stay there
and they will stay there for very long
time i think it can happen again it can
happen certainly
more quickly than we might think a way
to prevent it is through education
better education better knowledge we
have to
stay in the process of learning to
spread the awareness
members there
miss margaret friedlander dear
colleagues
the horrors that took place in auschwitz
are unspeakable
but we must speak this is a day
of remembrance today
the 27th of january marks our collective
responsibility
to remember the unspeakable atrocities
committed towards all the victims of the
holocaust
six million jewish people
the romney people the lgbtiq communities
and many others
that were stripped of their dignity
because of their ethnicity
identity
race
behaviors or because of their political
all religious beliefs
the nazi regime callously murdered 17
million men
women and children and inflicted
unimaginable suffering and pain on
millions more
while other silence stood complicit
we remember those
that perished and those
that survived survivors burdened with
unimaginable hardship
survivors
such as zilli schmidt and sony vice
whom we are fortunate to have present
with us
online today
we remember those that to paraphrase the
title of margaret friedlandle's book had
to try to make a life
in a world that tried to completely
annihilate them and their families
how low
humanity
sank
on holocaust remembrance day we remember
crimes committed against humanity in the
past
but we also remember the importance to
speak up
in the present
united in diversity we speak up against
holocaust deniers
against conspiracy myths
against disinformation
and against violence of every kind
that target and single out members of
our communities
because despite decades of effort we
have not yet done enough to combat
discrimination
in recent years across europe
anti-semitic attacks are increasing and
our children are no exception to this
violence
only two days ago
a twelve-year-old boy from livorno in
tuscany
was insulted
kicked and spat on
simply because he is jewish
fear
still exists
because anti-semitism
still exists
and because the fundamental right
to be free from discrimination
irrespective of gender
race
ethnic origin or sexual orientation is
threatened daily
we cannot allow complacency
we cannot allow impunity for acts of
hatred that instilled fear in members of
our communities
holocaust survivor and nobel prize
winner elie wiesel said
i swore never
to be silent
whenever and wherever
human beings and your suffering
and humiliation
we must always take sides
and the european parliament will always
take aside the side of respect
the side of human dignity the side of
equality the european parliament will
never
be silent and today
we lit up the european parliament in
honor of all the victims of the
holocaust
we must consciously act
every day and in whatever we do to
ensure that our communities are not
marginalized by exclusion hatred and
indifference and we must learn
and we must educate
the 2005 united nations resolution that
designated the 27th january as the
international commemoration day in
memory of holocaust victims
also emphasizes the importance of
educating about holocaust history so
that the darkest chapter of european
history
never ever repeats itself
the united nations resolution calls for
actively preserving all holocaust sites
that served as nazi death camps
concentration camps forced labor camps
and prisons and these sites as we've
seen
offer history lessons in themselves
sites such as the alsace moselle
memorial in shirmek just a few
kilometers away from the european
parliament's official seat in strasbourg
where through knowledge
and education current and future
generations can learn
about the hunger
first
disease
violence and death that were part of the
everyday life of holocaust victims and
they can never learn
to ever forget
today we mark 77 years since the
liberation of the auschwitz birkenau
camp a liberation from evil
that signaled that there was still hope
the european project was built as a
political political manifestation
of never again
a response to the horrors of the third
reich with the ambition to integrate
democratic countries together in the
hope
for a better future
it stemmed from the bold ideal
that strength could be extracted from
tragedy
that from the ashes of our common
history we could forge
a common destiny
a destiny where the values of peace
fairness
openness
and cooperation could be instilled in us
all because this
is our europe
and today it is truly an honor for this
european parliament to welcome holocaust
survivor margot friedlander
your lifelong commitment to combat
discrimination through initiatives like
the margaret friedlander award that
supports young people in standing up
against modern day forms of
anti-semitism racism and exclusion and
your lifelong dedication in sharing the
message of your life is an inspiration
to us all and for this we thank you
[Applause]
forty years ago simon vale held the same
role that i hold today the first
president of a democratically elected
european parliament was herself
a former inmate of auschwitz birkenau
and so this responsibility that we must
carry as a house of democracy is not
only institutional but also deeply
personal and we will honor the legacy of
the holocaust victims
by never forgetting
by never being
complacent
and by always
always speaking up
[Applause]
so we will now listen uh to a guitar
piece by french schneidberger called hal
gutter in memory of my people
this composition is a tune handed down
by sinti ancestors to the musician's
grandmother and it is dedicated to the
sinti and roma people persecuted during
the holocaust
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i will now give the floor to miss
margaret friedlander for her address the
floor is yours
madam president of the european
parliament
madam president of the european
commission
president of the european council
distinguished members of the european
parliament
ladies and gentlemen
it is a great honour for me to be able
to speak to you today
a few days ago
on the 20th of january
an event at the house of the vance
conference in berlin recalled that
80 years ago
the
national socialist leadership
[Music]
had decided on the unimaginable 80 years
ago
what they called the final solution in
other words
the murder of the european jews
today
throughout europe
we are commemorating the liberation
of the
concentration and extermination camp
auschwitz
on january the 27th 1945
this remembrance is particularly
important today
it wasn't only in germany that people
looked on and did nothing to protect
their german neighbors
in many other countries too
hardly anyone lifted a finger
to save their jewish neighbours from
deportation
denmark was a laudable exception
where the
general population
with the full knowledge of the
government protected and saved their
jewish fellow citizens
but unfortunately that was the exception
only need to think of the evian
conference
where
all the states except the dominican
republic
refused
to accept jewish refugees
perhaps the vance conference
would never have happened if the evian
conference hadn't
failed
i was the only one in my family to
survive
my wonderfully gifted brother ralph
was taken
from our berlin
apartment by the gestapo in january 1943
and put on a transport to the east
he was 17 and a half years old at the
time
neither my mother nor i
were at home at the time
when mother came home
the apartment was sealed
a neighbor then told her what had
happened
my mother didn't wait for me
she
herself
turned herself into the gestapo
to accompany my brother
but she left a message for me with the
neighbors
when
i came home
they should tell me the following
i'm going with ralph
wherever that might be
margaret
should try
to make her life
that was the last i ever heard from my
mother and brother
at the time i was 21 years old
and at that moment i was all alone in
berlin
without my mother
or my brother
and no other family members
i managed to find good people who hid me
these people
did something that could have cost them
their lives
they shared their homes and their food
with me
i had about 16 helpers and
many different shelters
where i was hidden for shorter or longer
periods of time
and often in a very precarious situation
until
15 months later
in april 1944
i was
arrested and deported to
the camp to heisenstadt
it was mainly many old people who were
deported to heisenstadt married couples
were separated
the old people had to sleep in a small
room in two-story wooden frames with
straw mattresses
there was nothing else there other than
the wooden bed
where
you could hang up your few items on a
nail there were no toilets or washing
facilities
they had to go outside to primitive
latrines
and wash at the well
in the cold winter too
they got less to eat
than the workers
they
starved to death
and
died miserably just a short while after
their arrival
at the beginning of february 1945 a
transport of more than 200 men and 20
women
arrived from vulcau
these people were near previously had
been dispatched from tourism
to
work on an eichmann project
to
build alternative quarters for the high
security main office
adolf friedlander had come back to
theresenstat on this transport
we met by chance in the corridor of the
barracks
where we were both living on different
floors
i didn't recognize him
because he had his arm in a sling
his
head and neck were also
bandaged he got closer he called me by
my name
margaret margot
because
we had known each other from berlin from
the jewish cultural association
we were so pleased to meet someone
from before
and we then tried to meet secretly now
and again
at the end of april 1945 i together with
others
was called to help with a planned
transport
when a long train with cattle cars
arrived
we didn't know
what to expect
when the doors were pushed open
i experienced something that i would
never forget
people who barely looked human
fell
[Music]
or were pushed out of the
overcrowded wagon
you could hardly tell the living from
the dead
their eyes were sunken
only their noses stood out of their
faces
almost all of them were a kind of
striped pajama
prisoners clothes
just rags
hanging off their bodies
instead of shoes
they were wooden wooden clogs
many
had only one on or none left on
many had bruises on their legs
which were very swollen
others were just skeletons
something fell into my arms
a person
so weak
that i had to
carry him
he was as light as a feather
someone plucked my arm
margot don't you recognize me
but how could i recognize this figure
who told me he was arnold kirschberg
they all came from auschwitz
that was the first time i heard the name
auschwitz
because we had always ever only been
told that the transports were going to
the east
so
auschwitz
was the east
and that's where these people came from
shortly before the liberation of
auschwitz on the 27th of january
they were sent on a death march
the ss
did
everything possible
to ensure that the survivors didn't fall
into the hands of the russians
so that the allies
wouldn't learn of the
full extent of the extermination in the
concentration camps
these people had been on the road for
almost three months first of all on foot
in a long column
it was only men
even
if at first glance they seemed
sexless like
skeletons most of them had long since
died
shot
or starved
staffed to death or died of exhaustion
at some point the last survivors had
been picked up crammed into cattle cars
and
sent to tyresensthat which was one of
the last camps that had not yet been
liberated
they had no food they were together with
typhoid sufferers and in terrible dirt
many didn't survive
but there was still
a few hundred or so who fell towards us
at that moment the east got a name
at that moment
we found out about the death camps
and at that moment
i
that
realized
would never see my mother and brother
again
i no longer had any hope
i wanted to survive because i wanted to
see my family again
what was the point of my survival now
there were many rumors circulating in
the camp that the war would soon be over
our mood was tense
we noticed first from the behavior of
the ss men that something
had changed
they were running around
loading their belongings onto trucks
their possessions that also included
everything that they had stolen from us
we waited eagerly
at some point
the gate opened
and the first trucks left the ghetto
we could hardly believe it
were we soon going to be liberated
a few days later
it was may the fifth
commander ram left the camp
an ss
man stood at the gate
and pulled in the swastika flag and took
it with him
in vehicles that were still reasonably
drivable
they sat tightly packed together
and
drove out of the camp in a column
from the windows in the barracks where i
lived
i could see the road that led to prague
that was actually strictly forbidden but
i still dared to look
and i saw an open jeep
with a red cross flag
stretched over the bonnet
a little later
this flag was flying
at the
commandant
office
a strange mood spread through the camp
without us knowing what was happening
but no one was cheering and no one was
happy
no one changed their daily routine
the ss
have disappeared
have we now been liberated
how did it feel to be liberated
we had waited so long for this moment
and now
it was here
but
we couldn't
believe it
for three days we lived exactly as
before
even though the red cross was there
the red army had not yet taken to
raisinstat
everything held its breath
then
the russians took over the commandant's
office
the soviet army
[Music]
had been marching along the road to
prague
just outside the camp since the early
hours
there were open trucks
cars fully loaded with solders
tired soldiers were riding on tired
horses
and now the gates were open
i was standing at the open gate for the
first time
there were no guards anymore
no one could stop me from going out
nevertheless i simply stood there
am i dreaming
is it really true that i've survived
i carefully take a few steps out
onto the road
but i don't want to leave
i simply want to see if it's true that i
can go out
without being shot
next to me is adolf
friedlander we look at one another
we
go through the liberation together
on may the eighth nineteen forty five
moment that we will never forget
we were liberated
what was my mood
was i happy
no
i don't think so
because now
i was about to find out what had
happened to my
beloved mother
and brother
i don't really know exactly how i
survived tourism strat
from the start
i experienced the ghettos if through a
veil
every day i simply did what i had to do
now
i was liberated
but even that seemed unreal to me
we stood at the gate
unable to move
unable to do anything
after the red army
had passed by it became a little quieter
we waited to see what would happen next
suddenly
everything was full of doctors and
nurses
who first
tried
to bring
the typhoid fever under control
lice ridden straw mattresses were burned
everything
was sprayed with disinfectant
medicines were brought in
and we were given soap
and
toothpaste so that we could finally
wash and brush our teeth
heavy trucks brought in crates and sacks
with food
for provisions in the kitchens
especially rice
so that the sick
could get some
light nourishment
then something happened that we could
hardly believe
people came to the camp
they were wearing on the back of their
jackets
large swastikas
under the supervision of the russians
they were now doing the dirty and heavy
work
that we had done so far
now i realized
that i was liberated
and my first thought was
yes
there is a god
a dolphin
i sometimes went for a walk
we would sit on a bench by a river
and
talked about everything that moved us
one day in june
when we were sitting on our bench again
adolf asked me
could you imagine a life with me
adolf wanted to marry me
but there was more to getting married
so i had always thought
i wasn't in love with adolf
i was simply frozen
i needed time to become a person again
to be able to feel
until now
feelings for me had only ever been
associated with pain and memories
adolf felt exactly the same
maybe it was this pain
that brought us closer together
more than being in love
we longed for a normal life
i said yes
adolf gave me his father's wedding ring
wedding rings
were the only thing
that wasn't taken away into heisenstadt
adolf had always worn it throughout the
camp period and managed to save it
i would never take it off
adolf wanted to get married as soon as
possible
on the 26th of june 1945
we were married by rabbi noy house
according to the jewish right
on the 30th of june
four days after our wedding
adolf received a telegram from his
sister ilse from the usa
that gave him a new goal
i think it was the 10th of january
1945
when we left
this time in cattle cars
but they were supposed to bring us to
freedom
and then until july
1946 we were in
degendorf in bavaria in a dp displaced
persons camp
and we left germany in a troop transport
to america
where
we arrived in new york on july the 28th
1946
we were warmly welcomed by adolf sister
and husband
a cousin and friends
unfortunately
i no longer have time to write about
the 64 years
that i lived in new york from 1946 to
2010.
together with adolf ever since the 50s
we
went on
many travels at least 30 trips to europe
but we only once went to germany for
three days
to munich
but we never went to berlin
despite various invitations adolf never
wanted to go back to germany
and certainly not to berlin
the country of his mother's murderers
after 52 happy years of marriage
my husband died
on december the 25th 1997.
now
i had to take my life back into my own
hands
at the senior club of the jewish
cultural organization
the
on the 92nd street
i took
writing courses where i began to write
about my life
a documentary filmmaker
heard about it
and wanted to make a film with me
and i got an invitation
from the berlin senate
so in 2003
i returned to berlin for the first time
when i arrived in berlin in june 2003 i
went for a walk on the first day
on a street that i knew well i stopped
and said
my berlin
i'm so happy to have been born in such a
beautiful city
in 2005
the film
don't call it time they
came out
about my first trip home after 61 years
in berlin
there i
made more and more new friends
these friends encouraged me
to write about my life
in my mother tongue
after decades
i wrote
my memoirs
in german
when i couldn't fall asleep
i would take my paper and pencil to bed
give free reign to my thoughts
and
at those moments
the memories gave me the right words
in the spring of 2008
when my memoirs were published as a book
under the title
try to make your life
it was the beginning of my fourth life
i still lived in new york
commuting across the atlantic
because i was receiving more and more
invitations for readings from germany
and at some point the moment had come
two years later
in 2010
i made it come true
at the age of 88
i came back to berlin
not only were there many friends there
waiting for me
but
i returned with a message
that
since that day i have been
saying again and again to students at my
readings
after living in america for 64 years
i've come back
to talk to you
to reach out to you
to ask you
to become
[Music]
the contemporary witnesses that we will
no longer have for much longer
it's for you be people
people did it because they didn't
recognize people as human beings
you can't love
everyone
but
everyone is due respect
there is no such thing as christian
jewish or muslim blood
there is only
human blood
we are all the same
what happened
happened
we can no longer change it
but it must never never happen again
i'm not only speaking for the six
million jews
who were killed
but for all those who
innocently
were murdered by the nazi regime
it is for you
for your children
for your descendants
that is my mission
i
say it again
be human
ladies and gentlemen
you
in this house
represent millions of people on this
continent
whose
democratically elected representatives
you are
this means
a great responsibility because even now
we are all facing
major challenges
it is with great concern
that i see that the holocaust
like the
nazi
war of conquest and extermination
is
increasingly
being forgotten
we are the last survivors who can bear
witness
today i see how the memory of what
happened
is politically abused sometimes it's
even ridiculed
and
trampled underfoot
it is with disbelief
that
now
as a 100 year old
i've had to see how
symbols of our exclusion by the nazis
the so-called jewish star
star of david are shamelessly
being used
today by the new enemies of democracy
on the streets
to style themselves right in the midst
of a democracy as victims
on a day like today
we must stand together
so that the memory of the
holocaust remains
alive
and is not abused by anyone
ladies and gentlemen
what has happened cannot change
i myself have had to experience
how people
have denied other people their humanity
first
to marginalize them
to rob them
to burn their places of worship
and finally to murder them
this must never
happen again
that is why we now
must be
vigilant and not look the other way as
we did then
hatred racism and anti-semitism
must not be the last word in history
i have had to see with my very own eyes
and experience where this leads
today
on the 27th of january
we commemorate
the millions and millions of innocent
victims
of
the nazis
remembrance
has a tremendous significance for us
today
people regardless of their skin color
religion or origin
have to be treated as human beings and
that is especially true today
humanity
tolerance and respect
are more important than ever
for peaceful coexistence
that is my wish
on this important day of
remembrance
and commemoration
for the world
for europe
for all of us
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much from the bottom of
all our hearts
i will now give the floor to president
charles michelle for his address
madam president of the european
parliament
been president of the commission
ladies and gentlemen
margaret friedlander
it's not easy
to be here before you and to take the
floor
after
the power of such
[Music]
a testimony after the power the intimacy
the personal quality
the
strength the courage
and the lucidity
that we've heard from you
in this parliament which is this symbol
of european democracy
i'd like to begin by expressing my
admiration
and my gratitude to you
madam margaret friedlander
admiration for your courage and
commitment
to bear witness
as you do today
it commands our respect
and
it forces
each citizen
each of us here today
to reflect
on our own commitment
to defend and improve the society
and the world we live in
and allow me to express our gratitude
dear margaret friedlander
for your words of wisdom
your commitment
has brought you to this parliament today
the home of european democracy to
commemorate the holocaust
when europe jewish people
were targeted
for annihilation
holocaust
choose
home democracy
europe
allow me to say a few words
about some of the convictions
that link these powerful
and resilient words
the holocaust was a european tragedy
some people
especially the younger generation
may see this event
as remote
and abstract
even mythical
a global commemoration
of a unique symbolic
and laundry tragedy
yet
it was
on european soil that this unimaginable
crime was perpetrated
perpetrated by europeans
against fellow europeans
the result
of unbridled hatred
and we europeans
are all ass
to this history
our history
and we are all the guardian
of this memory
our memory
this gives europe and europeans
all of us here today
a special responsibility
the responsibility of guardians
earth pass
and this responsibility becomes all the
more consequential
because unfortunately
we will not always be accompanied
by survivors to bear witness
ladies and gentlemen
europe is the home of european jews
exactly like it is the home for all
europeans
europe would not be what it is today
without the contributions of the jewish
people over many centuries
contributing to our societies to the
sciences economy culture
and to the vibrancy of our european
intellectual life
europe is home for jewish people
that's why today
with anti-semitism resurgent in europe
the idea the jewish people are under
attack just because their jews is
absolutely unbearable
and that's why the strategy
that the european commission adopted
last year to combat anti-semitism and to
secure a future for jewish life in
europe is so vital
and this plan
includes support for the creation of a
network of fiona european ambassadors to
promote the memory of the shore
ladies and gentlemen this parliament
is the house of european democracy
anti-semitism
is a denial of democracy
when we defend jewish life
when we promote jewish life
along with the life of all communities
in europe
when we fight discrimination when we
protect minorities
we defend european democracy
defending european democracy means
fighting anti-semitism and all
discrimination
dear friends ladies and gentlemen
it was therefore no coincidence that
those who plant organized and
perpetrated the genocide of the jews
were also those who in 1933
burnt down the rich touch the german
parliament
this building was symbolically restored
some 60 years later and we inhabited by
the bundestag when democracy was
restored throughout reunified germany
combating anti-semitism today
means from batting the hate speech and
the transparency terrorists that have
taken root and thrive
especially online
and this parliament the forum for
european democratic public debate is a
place where this essential battle is
being waged
finally
i'd like to return to the holocaust
and to the crucial role that this event
plays in shaping
our european spirit
our european vision
the european union is the strongest and
most decisive response to the tragedy of
the student world tour
a project of peace
of solidarity
of shared prosperity
a political project
forward-looking
and founded on solid values
and it is this tragedy the holocaust
that has instilled us europeans
with a special sense
of duty
the duty to defend
and to promote respect for human dignity
and freedom
here at home
and throughout the world
the duty
to fight all that discriminates
all that weakens
and all that this possesses or even
excludes
as the jews have been in our european
history
this duty
this fight
is no different
than the fight for democracy
they are one
they are the same
dear friends
it's precisely because we've experienced
the speakable horror of the holocaust
that today
we work so intently
for europe that's home to democracy
democracy
this is our struggle for democracy
is never fully won
never one forever but it is
the worthiest of battles
it requires commitment from all of us
just
like the tireless commitment
shown by you margaret lender
sherman friedlander
dear
margaret friedlander we want to say to
you
that we feel great admiration gratitude
for the poignant message the powerful
message
that
has inspires
powerful emotions but also hope strength
thank you very much
thank you very much president michelle i
now invite president ursula wonderlion
for her address
president mitzola president michelle
honorable members
libra for friedlander
i think it was hard for all of us to
hold back our tears
when we are listening to you
you margaret friedlander
a survivor
a witness
of the greatest tragedy
in european history
you told us about the images that got
stuck in a young woman's
mind
and in her memory
the horror you witnessed
you told us of how hard it was
to find your way back to life
and yes this was the nazi's plan
not just to exterminate millions of
people based on ethnicity religion or
sexual orientation
but also to take humanity out of the
people
to strip them of all dignity all
identity all love for life
but your testimony margaret feedlander
and your energy at 100 years
shows that dignity and identity are
indestructible
i can't even imagine how hard it must be
before friedlander
to bring these memories back to the
surface
and i want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart
it is the greatest service
the greatest act of love for all of us
and future generations
because you make us see
you make us free
our freedom
is built on the memory of the holocaust
because the very reason why our union
was founded lies in two simple worlds
never
again
ni vida
gratitude is even greater
as a german
with europe in her heart
because i feel the deep scar in my
country's history
and the indelible responsibility in our
collective history
we want to keep our eyes wide open
we want to understand what happened
and why
so it never happens again
and you lieberfowl friedlander made us
see
and made us understand
there's one thing about your life that
strikes me immensely spoke about it
indeed right after the war you decided
to leave germany and europe
because the pain was too big
and the past
would never get past you
but then
20 years ago
you decided to come back
even if the memory was still alive in
fact precisely because the memory had to
remain alive
you came back
so that history could never come back
and you explained your decisions
as we've just heard with the words
what happened can't be changed
but now
it's up for you
the next generation
and yes the next generation they deserve
to hear your story they became your
mission
and today i would like to tell you
your mission is our mission too
it is because of this mission
that we have to come up
with our thoughts and our work
and this is why we came with our first
strategy to combat anti-semitism
and to foster jewish life in europe
we have listened to the warning that is
coming from the people like you
anti-semitism has not disappeared it
still poisons our societies
a stunning 70 percent of european jews
don't feel safe
when wearing a kippah or a star of david
and throughout the pandemic
jews have been the target of all sorts
of conspiracy theories
and hate speech
but this time we won't close our eyes
ni vida never again
preserving the memory is the first step
to avoid that history repeats itself
with the strategy we are working so that
all schools in europe teach the history
of the showa
we want to raise youth ambassadors
of remembrance as the next generation
who will keep the memory alive
and we will encourage students to learn
about
europe's jewish culture and tradition
for instance just ten days ago
jewish people around the world
planted trees to celebrate
tu b'shvat
the year of trees our children should
know about it because it's part of our
european culture and history and because
it teaches us to take care of our planet
and our future
libra margaret friedlander honorable
members
today we have listened to the story
of how life and dignity were taken away
from millions right here in europe
people were killed and humiliated
their names replaced by numbers on their
forearm and all of this
just because
of who they were
the union we want to build is a place
where everyone can be whoever they want
to be
a place where jewish women like simon
vale a survivor of holocaust can race to
become
the president of this proud european
parliament
a place where everyone is entitled to
the same rights and is treated with the
same dignity
and this is what
keeping the memory alive
truly means
a continent that is finally united in
its beautiful diversity
feel dunk thank you libra margaret
friedlander for sharing your memory with
us
long live europe thank you
thank you president of wonderland i ask
you now dear colleagues before closing
the ceremony to join me for a minute of
silence
and to close i now invite philip gruffa
violin and raphael val fish cello
to close our ceremony with the kadish mr
val fish is the son
of anita lasker wolfish a surviving
member of the women's orchestra of
auschwitz whom we had the honor to have
here in the european parliament on the
occasion of the 75th anniversary of the
liberation of auschwitz
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
no
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much to all of you this
session is adjourned and the seating is
closed
uh
foreign